und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend wir kämpfen den Kampf
unseres Lebens und wir sind dabei ihn zu
verlieren warnte UN-Generalsekretär
Antonio guteresch heute auf der
Weltklimakonferenz in Sharm el Sheikh es
ist der Tag der Großkopferten in Ägypten
Bundeskanzler Scholz ist da
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
der französische Präsident macron und
sie alle haben das gleiche Problem sie
werden für mehr Klimaschutz für mehr
erneuerbare und den Verzicht auf Kohle
gleichzeitig aber kann ein reiches Land
wie Deutschland nicht mehr als Vorreiter
gelten Klimaziele gerissen
Kohlekraftwerke wieder angeworfen über
den Auftritt von Politikern die sehr
gerne Klimaschützer wären berichtet
golini atai
Hochglanz und hoffnungsvolle Musik das
ägyptische Werbevideo zur
Weltklimakonferenz gaukelt eine heile
Welt vor
drinnen im Plenum klingen die Worte
düster und drastisch
UN-Generalsekretär gut die Welt sei auf
dem Highway zur Klimahülle mit dem Fuß
auf dem Gaspedal entweder Solidarität
oder Selbstmord Mart er die Staatslenker
die Front auf diesem Klimagipfel
verläuft zwischen Nord und Süd Reich und
Arm die Entwicklungsländer pochen auf
Entschädigungen für immer neue
Klimakatastrophen in ihren Ländern die
Hauptverursacher der Klimakrise meiden
das Wort Entschädigung weil sie nicht in
Haft genommen werden wollen
Auftritt Olaf Scholz er verspricht etwas
Neues eine Art klimaversicherung damit
die meistgefährdeten Staaten beim
nächsten Extremwetter nicht noch mehr
Schulden aufnehmen müssen als
g7-präsidentschaft wollen wir gemeinsam
mit den valner Rebel 20 ein globalen
Schutzschirm gegen klimarrisiken
aufspannen
für diesen Schutzschirm und die
klimarisikofinanzierung stellt
Deutschland 170 Millionen Euro zur
Verfügung ist das genug nein sagen die
Betroffenen der Schirm Falle viel zu
klein aus und schleichende
Klimaveränderungen wie der steigende
Meeresspiegel würden damit gar nicht
aufgefangen
der globale Schirm wird mit ziemlich
viel Skepsis gesehen er scheint mehr ein
versicherungsschwindel zu sein als
wirklich konkretes Handeln wir denken
dass das eher den Chefs der
Versicherungsunternehmen zugutekommt als
den betroffenen Gemeinschaften
für die Afrikaner ist klar was die
Industrieländer da versprechen und wie
sie gerade handeln dass sei alles
einfach nicht glaubwürdig
wir müssen Entschädigungen verlangen
denn Deutschland hatte uns doch gesagt
dass es mit der Kohle aufgehört hat aber
es hat eben nicht alle Kohlekraftwerke
dicht gemacht da ist sie die Klima
Ungerechtigkeit ich weiß das Kanzler
Scholz nicht darüber reden will für ihn
zählt nur sein ökonomisches Kalkül aber
das macht er auf dem Rücken der
Afrikaner
die Vertrauenskrise zwischen Nord und
Süd sie spielt schon so lange dass sie
die gesamte Konferenz aus den Angeln
heben könnte
und mit dem Kanzler nach Sharm el Sheikh
geflogen ist unsere Hauptstadt
Korrespondentin shakunta la beneschel
tschuldigung guten Abend wie glaubwürdig
sind eigentlich die Ankündigung des
Kanzlers der zu Hause ein 200 Milliarden
entlastungsprogramm auflegt und in
Ägypten 170 Millionen für die
Entschädigung von klimarisiken
verspricht
ja die Diskrepanz die wird hier
natürlich von Kritikern wahrgenommen
allerdings muss man der fairnesshalber
dazu sagen dass die 170 Millionen nur
eine Anschubfinanzierung sind für ein
Instrument das hier jahrelang in der
diskussionsschleife festgehangen hat und
diese Anschubfinanzierung soll jetzt
dabei helfen dieses Instrument mal ins
Leben überhaupt erstrufen zu können an
dem Konzept haben die am meisten
betroffenen Länder
mitgearbeitet an dem Entwurf und wenn
der globale Schutzschirm funktioniert
dann soll er sehr viel schneller als es
jetzt möglich ist Gelder zur Verfügung
stellen für schwerstbetroffene Länder
zum Beispiel denken wir an Pakistan und
die Flutkatastrophe mit einem globalen
Schutzschirm so ist die Idee sollte da
möglichst schnell dann Geld fließen
umschäden auch zu beheben und das ist
etwas worauf die schwerstbetroffenen
Länder hier sehr lange gewartet haben
kritik gibt es auch daran dass westliche
Regierungschefs darunter auch der
Kanzler die Klimakonferenz nutzen um
neue Verträge zu Erschließung von
Gasfeldern zum Beispiel in Afrika zu
unterschreiben das ist ja wohl so
ziemlich das Gegenteil von Klimaschutz
oder
ja das ist ein klarer Widerspruch zu den
kräftigen Bekenntnis aus den fossilen
Energien möglichst schnell auszusteigen
aber was hier auch klar ist ist das ist
nicht realistisch ist dass sich dieser
Kurs in Deutschland in der nächsten Zeit
ändert solange die erneuerbaren Energien
nicht die Lücke geschlossen haben wird
weiter auf Gas gesetzt und es wird eben
dann auch neues Gas gefördert werden das
bedeutet aber hier auch dass sich alle
erst einmal darum bemühen wollen mehr
Tempo zu machen bei den Erneuerbaren ob
das dann gelingt ist eine andere Frage
aber für Olaf Scholz zum Beispiel heißt
das dass er morgen hier viele bilaterale
Gespräche führen wird aber auch
Veranstaltungen innerhalb hier des der
Konferenz besuchen wird in der es
vorrangig auch geht um neue Netzwerke
grünen Wasserstoff windkraft und
Solarenergie um da einer internationale
Kooperation herzustellen wie gesagt
alles eine Absicht alles Verhandlungen
das ist aber auf jeden Fall Thema Morgen
und ein paar kritische Fragen wird der
Kanzler wohl auch beantworten müssen
vielen Dank Herr gunterla nach Sharm el
Sheikh
wenn alle Autos künftig elektrisch
fahren sollen und das sollen sie ja um
den klimaschädlichen CO2-Ausstoß zu
begrenzen braucht man Batterien und zwar
große und leistungsfähige um diese
herzustellen braucht man Lithium
ungefähr 6 Kilo dieses leitfähigen
Metalls stecken heute in einem
durchschnittlichen Elektroauto der Run
auf den Rohstoff hat längst begonnen zum
Beispiel hier im sogenannten
lithiumdreieck zwischen Chile Bolivien
und Argentinien unter der Oberfläche
gewaltiger Salzwüsten werden die größten
lithiumvorkommen der Welt vermutet der
Abbau jetzt schon ein Riesengeschäft ob
die Gewinnung des Metalls dass das Klima
eigentlich retten soll nicht selbst das
Klima schädigt darüber wird noch
gestritten Christoph rückerath berichtet
aus Chile es sind Farben die fremd
wirken mitten im grau-braun der Atacama
salzebene in Chile aber sie strahlen
hinaus in die ganze Welt
hier wird Lithium gewonnen der Stoff aus
dem die modernen Akkus sind die vom
Smartphone bis zum Elektroauto unseren
Alltag antreiben seit Jahrtausenden
schlummert es unter der Oberfläche
gelöst in konzentriertem Salzwasser der
Sohle hier in einer der größten
lithiumminen der Welt pumpen Sie es an
die Oberfläche
Atacama hat zwei große Vorteile zum
einen ist die lithium-konzentration in
der Sohle die aus dem Salar gewonnen
wird die höchste der Welt und zweitens
hat der Salah die besten Voraussetzungen
für den gewinnungsprozess den wir hier
anwenden
den erledigt nämlich die Sonne allein
durch die Verdunstung des Wasseranteils
der Sohle wird diese immer
konzentrierter die Farbe ändert sich
weil sich schrittweise unterschiedliche
Mineralien absetzen ist der
lithium-anteil hoch genug wird die
Flüssigkeit mit Tanklastwagen in einer
Raffinerie gebracht wo sie das Lithium
extrahieren
die Nachfrage boomt und das bereitet
Umweltschützern Sorge felicium wird
nicht nur Sohle abgepumpt es braucht
auch Frischwasser und das ausgerechnet
in der Wüste
voller Zorn schaut Christian espinula
auf die Miene unten im Salat
sie werden ein Heiligtum aus Abfall
hinterlassen
Christian gehört zum indigenen Volk der
Lika natai sie besiedeln die quebrardas
die fruchtbaren Flusstäler oberhalb des
Salah seit Jahrhunderten betreiben sie
Landwirtschaft mit Hilfe eines uralten
Bewässerungssystems in den letzten
Jahren ist das Wasser hier knapper
geworden Klimawandel sagen die ein die
Bergbaukonzerne und die Gier der Welt
nach Lithium sagt Christian
was für einen großen Teil der Menschheit
ein Fortschritt sein mag bedeutet für
uns Zerstörung das Problem des
Klimawandels soll von denen gelöst
werden die es verursacht hätten und
nicht auf dem Rücken der indigenen
Völker atakarmas fordert er der Chef
Hydrologe der Minengesellschaft
widerspricht den indigenen Gemeinden
würde kein Wasser abgegraben die
Grundwasserbrunnen der Miene seien
weiter unten im Tal und die Sohle komme
ohnehin aus einer anderen Schicht als
das Grundwasser schon jetzt sei der
Verbrauch unter den Grenzwerten und man
würde ihn weiter reduzieren
nach unseren Erkenntnissen und dem
Überwachungsnetz dass wir auf dem
gesamten Gebiet errichtet haben sehen
wir keinen Zusammenhang zwischen der
Entnahme von Sohle im Kerngebiet und dem
was in den höher gelegenen Teilen des
atacama-beckens geschieht die hängen
hauptsächlich von den Niederschlägen ab
doch Studien weisen darauf hin dass das
komplexe Atacama Ökosystem noch lange
nicht ausreichend erforscht ist und dass
die flüssigkeitskreisläufe hier
wesentlich langsamer ablaufen als
bislang angenommen es ist also gut
möglich dass die warenauswirkungen des
lithium-abbaus erst in Jahrzehnten
sichtbar werden könnten
und dann lässt uns noch diese Nachricht
aufhorchen ein russischer Geschäftsmann
der gleichzeitig Chef der Söldnertruppe
Wagner ist Jewgeni prigorcin hat heute
erklärt dass sich Russland in die
US-Wahlen eingemischt habe
Jewgeni pregorian also der wegen seiner
Catering-Firma Putins Koch genannt wird
sagte heute wörtlich wir haben uns
eingemischt mischen uns ein und wir
werden uns weiterhin einmischen
sorgfältig genau chirurgisch und auf
unserer eigene Weise da wir wissen wie
es geht
Gregorian weiß tatsächlich wie es geht
denn er finanziert mindestens eine
trollfabrik einen Ort an dem Menschen
mit gefälschten Profilen online
Falschinformationen verbreiten wegen der
mutmaßlichen Wahlbeeinflussung steht
pregorian auf
us-sanktionslisten darüber müssen wir
reden mit unseren Korrespondenten in
Moskau und Washington zuerst zu viel
guten Abend nach Moskau
war ja eigentlich eher ein
Strippenzieher im Hintergrund welches
Interesse Russlands steckt dahinter sich
jetzt zu outen und die Einmischung
zuzugeben
ja um es kurz zu sagen Zweifel sehen
Moskau kann so eben sowohl Zweifel sehen
am Ausgang der Wahlen in den USA aber
auch an den demokratischen Institutionen
und ihren Prozessen ganz allgemein
gregorians Name der fiel ja schon 2017
im Zusammenhang mit eben Einmischung in
usa-wahlen damals hat er die trollfabrik
in St Petersburg leiten sollen die eben
dies Informationen und russische
Propaganda im Internet verbreitet hat
und damals hat er alles bestritten und
auch der Kreml hat bis heute alles
bestritten der Kreml bleibt auch nach
wie vor bei dieser offiziellen Haltung
während pregorian heute also
vorgeprescht ist so entsteht ein
irreführendes stimmengewehr an dessen
Ende eben Zweifel stehen an dem
Wahlausgang in den USA und Moskau
erreicht damit gleich mehreres erstens
nämlich dass
entschuldigung ich muss kurz gucken
erstens kann Moskau sich so als eine
Macht darstellen die das Geschehen auf
der Weltbühne weiterhin lenkt und das
obwohl es ja gerade als Militär macht
sein Image zu verlieren droht aufgrund
der Rückschläge in der Ukraine und
zweitens erzielt Russland an anderer
Front einen Erfolg nämlich im Hybriden
Kampf gegen westliche Demokratien
und weiter zu MRT Wissen nach Washington
Elmar wie reagiert man denn in
Washington auf dieses Eingeständnis am
Tag vor den Kongresswahlen
ja die Sprecherin des Weißen Hauses
carinen Jean Pierre hat vorhin gesagt
nichts Neues keine Überraschung man
spielt es also ein bisschen runter in
der Tat haben hier die
Sicherheitsbehörden schon Anfang Oktober
vor manipulationstaktiken im Umfeld der
Wahl gewarnt speziell aus Russland und
aus China und in Russland geht es in der
Tat um diese trollfabrik IAA internet
research agency wird sie genannt und man
kann jetzt schon nachweisen dass ganz
offenbar Trolle und Bots von dieser
trollfabrik über die sozialen Plattform
speziell im rechten politischen Spektrum
Stimmung machen da wird beispielsweise
Stimmung gegen die Ukraine Hilfe gemacht
das wäre Geldverschwendung Milliarden
von Dollar die in die Ukraine gehen
während sie doch eigentlich hier in den
USA für die Wirtschaftssituation
gebräucht gebraucht würden und es werden
Lügen verbreitet über die Kandidaten der
Demokratischen Partei zum Beispiel wenn
die gewählt würden würden sie alle
Drogendealer aus den Gefängnissen
freilassen also es geht ganz offenbar
darum das Wahlergebnis zu beeinflussen
und dann eben diese
Artikel sehen um wenn dann Kandidaten
sich hinterher weigern eine Niederlage
anzuerkennen eben das Chaos noch zu
befördern und es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass die US-Regierung in
den nächsten Tagen oder Wochen auf diese
Manipulationsversuche auch mit
Sanktionen reagieren wird
Russland sehr Zweifel wieder mal vielen
Dank euch beiden nach Moskau und nach
Washington und hier geht es weiter mit
Heinz Wolf und Nachrichten aus dem
Inland und dem Dauerstreit ums
Bürgergeld in dem sich auch heute keine
Lösung abzeichnet die Ampelkoalition und
die Union lehnten Kompromissvorschläge
der jeweils anderen Seite ab
CDU-Generalsekretär Chaya sagte nach
seinem Eindruck werde am Ende im
Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundestag und
Bundesrat über das Bürgergeld gesprochen
werden bislang plant die Regierung das
Bürgergeld als Nachfolger von Hartz IV
zum ersten Januar
für die preisbremsen bei Strom Gas und
Fernwärme sollen im kommenden Jahr 83
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung stehen mit
dieser Summe rechnet
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner im Rahmen
des Paketes von insgesamt 200 Milliarden
Euro mit dem bis 2024 die hohen
Energiepreise abgefedert werden sollen
im Ukraine Krieg beschuldigen sich Kiew
von Moskau gegenseitig zivile
Infrastruktur zu zerstören in der von
Russland kontrollierten Großstadt dann
jetzt Ketten angeblich ukrainische
Raketen die Zentrale der
Eisenbahnverwaltung getroffen und schwer
beschädigt Präsident silenski war
Russland terroristische Attacken auf
hakiv saporicia und Kiew vor 4,5
Millionen Menschen sein ohne Strom auch
im südlichen Carson bleibt die Lage
angespannt dort würde die Ukraine ihre
Truppen konzentrieren heißt es von
russischer Seite die Evakuierung der
Stadt ginge in das weiter
das Betriebsverfassungsgesetz wird in
diesem Monat 70 Jahre alt bei einem
Festakt zu diesem Anlass hat die
DGB-Vorsitzende fahimi unter anderem ein
initiativ- und Mitbestimmungsrecht von
Betriebsräten bei Maßnahmen für den
Klima- und Umweltschutz gefordert
Bundeskanzler Scholz Warp bei der
Veranstaltung heute Vormittag dafür das
Gesetz weiter zu entwickeln und sagte
eine Transformation der Wirtschaft
können nur gelingen wenn
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer mit
redeten
in diesem Jahrzehnten rund einen Monat
nach der Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen
steht die rot-grüne Koalition
spd-ministerpräsident weil und die
Grünen Spitzenkandidatin Hamburg
unterzeichneten den Koalitionsvertrag in
Hannover im Mittelpunkt steht dabei ein
landeseigenes Hilfsprogramm gegen die
Energiekrise von fast einer Milliarde
Euro morgen soll Ministerpräsident weil
im niedersächsischen Landtag für eine
weitere Amtszeit gewählt werden
steigende Energierechnungen und
Lebensmittelpreise vom murgste
corona-regeln Wirtschaftssanktionen
gegen Russland mehr Flüchtlinge die
Gründe warum Menschen besonders im Osten
Deutschlands wieder montags auf die
Straße gehen sind vielfältig Extremisten
von rechts schwafeln schon länger von
Diktatur und versuchen die Proteste für
sich zu nutzen nach dem Motto wir im
Osten sind aufmüpfiger weniger
Mainstream ticken anders wir im Osten
sind vielleicht grundlegend geerdeter
wird gleich ein Künstler im nächsten
Bericht sagen auf jeden Fall sind die im
Osten viel mehr als Wutbürger und
Montagsdemonstranten Melanie Haack
berichtet aus Erfurt
es ist ein dinkelstollen den Bäcker Paul
und sein Vater Wolfgang süpke aus dem
Burgkeller holen eine ganz neue Sorte
wie beim Wein
Verkostung auf der thüringischen
Ronneburg paul ist 25 schon als Kind
stand der in der Backstube jetzt ist er
selbst Bäckermeister und Content Creator
für seine Follower im Netz und wenn man
sich heutzutage nicht irgendwo darstellt
werde der stirbt das ist einfach so vor
30 Jahren hat Vater Wolfgang sich
selbstständig gemacht Neustart nach der
Wende mit Höhen und Tiefen Paul
aufgewachsen mit den Erfahrungen seiner
Eltern
es läuft gerade alles sehr schön und wir
leben gerade sehr gut in Deutschland
aber es ist nicht raus dass das
definitiv so ist weil ich glaube er hat
einfach die Erfahrung gemacht von der
Mangelwirtschaft und ich habe die
Erfahrung noch nie gemacht der
Firmenwagen Pauls Idee bewusst ein Stück
Heimat und Erinnerung in Erfurt hat der
Künstler Marc jung sein Atelier er ist
85er geboren reißt viel um die Welt doch
wo er herkommt da sieht der 37-Jährige
auch seine Identität ich würde schon
immer noch sagen ich bin trotzdem noch
ostdeutscher und ich glaube auch wenn
ich jetzt andere treffe die haben dann
auch schon noch mal einen anderen Humor
oder einen anderen irgendwie Lebensstil
einfach irgendwie so ein bisschen
grundlegend ein geerdeter aufgewachsen
im Erfurter Plattenbau eine Jugend als
Ringer in der Hip-Hop-Szene in den 90ern
geprägt von Brüchen und Unsicherheit das
politische Geschehen hält der Künstler
in Bildern fest seine Botschaft
ich bin ja einmal in so eine sind so
eine demo-situation geraten war dann
alles voll und von von von höcke
Demonstranten und der ganze andere Seite
war dann voll von den gegendemonstran
dass dann auch ein Bild raus entstanden
damals ich finde es halt erstaunlich wie
man mit der ganzen Geschichte wieder so
ähneln kann und aus der ganzen Sache
nichts gelernt hat in der Bäckerei süpke
in Sömmerda beschäftigen sie heute 60
Mitarbeiter suchen immer Fachkräfte das
Image des Ostens treibt Paul um weil
wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mal an
Dresden denkt dann denkt man immer als
erstes auch an dieser pegida Demos die
es da damals gab und für mich ist
Dresden ein absolut schöne Stadt eine
junge Generation die neu auf dieses Land
schaut mit Zielen und Hoffnungen sowie
Wolfgang 1989 beim ersten Besuch in
Westberlin ich habe da über den Markt
geguckt zum Wachturm und das war für
mich bekam die können sich vorstellen
sich immer wieder neu erfinden
weitermachen das hat Paul von seinem
Vater gelernt
[Musik]
die Kritik Europas an seinem Land sei
sehr arrogant und sehr rassistisch
beschwert sich der katarische
Außenminister altani und holt noch mal
größer gegen Deutschland aus sinngemäß
für eine Energiepartnerschaft sah sein
Land offenbar gut genug für eine
Fußball-WM aber anscheinend nicht es
gibt Ärger bei der WM im Wüsten Emirat
so viel steht fest die Kritik an Katar
reist nicht ab wegen der Behandlung
migrantischer Arbeiter wegen der
Verletzung von Menschenrechten wegen
mangelnder Pressefreiheit unserem
Reporter Jochen Breyer ist es nach viel
Überzeugungsarbeit trotzdem gelungen mit
der Kamera hinter die prachtkulisse zu
schauen herauskam ein unverstellter
Blick auf Frauen Schwule und die Welt
sowie Cutter sie sieht
das hier ist das was man in Katar auf
jeden Fall zu sehen bekommt Kulisse
gigantische Kulisse
vorbereitet für die WM
neue Autobahnen eine neue Metro
und das neue Prunkstück des Landes das
finalstadion unter den Sitzen
Klimaanlagen
kaum möglich aber ist der Blick hinter
die Kulissen das Leben der 300.000
katarischen Staatsbürger ist für Fremde
in der Regel Tabu nach vielen Gesprächen
werden wir doch hinter die Mauern
gelassen der ehemalige Nationalspieler
und offizielle wm-botschafter Khalid
Salman lädt uns zu sich nach Hause ein
eine Männerrunde sie schauen Fußball
jeden Abend auch die Bundesliga
8 Hausangestellte Arbeiten für die
Familie von Halle
alle Männer hier sind verheiratet wenn
ihre Frauen sie in der Öffentlichkeit
begleiten dann nur voll verschleiert
warum können Frauen nicht unverschleiert
sein Vergleich mal vor dir liegt eine
unverpackte Süßigkeit du weißt nicht ob
sie jemand berührt oder reingebissen hat
und eine verpackte welche nimmst du
wahrscheinlich die verpackte aber Frauen
sind doch keine Süßigkeiten aber es
könnte für sie besser sein als im Haus
zu bleiben mit einem Reichtum ihres
Vaters warum nur sollte eine Frau das
Haus verlassen auf das Geld die Fürsorge
die Liebe verzichten
einiges hat sich in Katar bewegt Frauen
studieren arbeiten und dürfen alleine
ins Ausland reisen wenn sie älter sind
als 25
aber es bleiben offene Fragen nach
Menschenrechten Meinungsfreiheit
Toleranz
viele Dinge hier ins Land kommen lass
uns zum Beispiel über Schwule reden das
wichtigste ist doch jeder wird
akzeptieren dass Sie hierher kommen aber
sie werden unsere Regeln akzeptieren
müssen
aber im Gesetz ist Homosexualität
verboten
weißt du was
eine Sünde
sein ist haram
ich bin kein strenger Muslim aber warum
ist es heran es ist ein geistiger
Schaden
an dieser Stelle geht der Pressesprecher
vom
WM-Organisationskomitee dazwischen
damage in the mind
der offizielle wm-botschafter findet
also die Liebe zwischen zwei Männern sei
eine Art Geisteskrankheit
die Frage der Menschenrechte sie bleibt
der dunkle Schatten auf der perfekten
Kulisse die Katar für die Fußball-WM
geschaffen hat
Geheimsache Kata die ganze sehr
sehenswerte Doku von Jochen Breyer und
Julia Friedrichs sehen sie morgen im ZDF
in der Reihe zDFzeit um 20 Uhr und hier
geht es weiter mit Nachrichten aus der
Wirtschaft und Heinz Wolfen bayerntag
hat heute Ergebnisse zum dritten Quartal
vorgelegt und da ist natürlich der
corona-impfstoff besonders interessant
auch mit Blick auf die angepassten
Impfstoffe bei der reale wie sieht das
Unternehmen die Entwicklung ja auch wenn
die Umsätze jetzt nicht mehr in den
Himmel wachsen rechnet das Unternehmen
trotzdem mit einem starken ja die
Hoffnung liegt tatsächlich auf dem neuen
umicon Booster auch geht biontech davon
aus dass noch eine ganze Weile jährliche
Auffrischungsimpfungen nötig sein werden
Licht und Schatten in der Bilanz Umsatz
und gewinnen sanken im Vergleich zum
Vorjahreszeitraum um jeweils mehr als 40
Prozent bei und Heck bleibt optimistisch
hebt seine Umsatzprognose für dieses
Jahr wegen des Omikron Boosters auf 16
bis 17 Milliarden Euro an der Kunststoff
der Mainzer ist einer der weltweit am
häufigsten eingesetzten gegen Corona in
China aber ist er noch nicht auf dem
Markt auch wenn es dafür immer wieder
Versuche gab wie kürzlich als
biontech-chef Sahin mit dabei war im
Kanzler Tross beim Antrittsbesuch von
Scholz in Peking Licht und Schatten auch
an der Börse die Aktie war mal mehr als
doppelt so viel wert wie heute mehr als
zehnmal so teuer wie beim Börsengang ist
sie aber immer noch der Einsatz in China
ist für Bayern Tag auch deswegen wichtig
weil die Mainzer die Impfstoff
Milliarden dazu nutzen möchten für ihre
Krebsforschung potenzielle Medikamente
sind in der Pipeline fünf davon könnten
schon in den nächsten Jahren zugelassen
werden vorausgesetzt ja vorausgesetzt
ihre Wirksamkeit bestätigt sich bei
realer vielen Dank
in etwa 40 Prozent der Familien mit ein
bis achtjährigen Kindern wird einer
Studie zufolge nur selten oder nie
vorgelesen in dem in Berlin
veröffentlichten vorlesemonitor wird
dafür geworben Vorlesen erzählen und das
Betrachten von Bildern von Anfang an in
den Alltag zu integrieren der
Hauptgeschäftsführer der Stiftung Lesen
Maas sagte wenn die Eltern nicht
vorlesen dann starten die Kinder mit
deutlich schlechteren
Bildungsvoraussetzungen in die Kitas und
in die Schulen
in der Fußball Champions League geht es
im Februar ins Achtelfinale für die
deutschen Teilnehmer ergab die Auslosung
diese Partien Bayern München muss
zunächst zu Paris St Germain Borussia
Dortmund spielt gegen den FC Chelsea
eintracht Frankfurt hat den SSC Neapel
gezogen und RB Leipzig trifft auf
Manchester City und in der Europa League
geht es zunächst in die Playoffs bei
leverkusen spielt gegen AS Monaco und
für Union Berlin geht es gegen Ajax
Amsterdam die Sieger qualifizieren sich
für das Achtelfinale
und das war es von uns wir empfehlen
Ihnen jetzt das montagskino in dem ein
Mörder seine Taten per Postkarte
ankündigt und danach um 23 Uhr gibt es
dann das heute schnell Update mit
Gundula Gause unter anderem mit einem
Interview mit Staatssekretär Jochen
flassbart von der Klimakonferenz in
Sharm el Sheikh und uns gibt es morgen
wieder einen schönen Abend und tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend seit Beginn der regelmäßigen
Wetteraufzeichnungen
1881 war es von Januar bis Oktober in
Deutschland noch nie so warm wie in
diesem Jahr 2022 ob auch das ganze Jahr
ein Rekordjahr wird müssen wir noch
abwarten bis Ende Dezember derzeit sieht
es aber nicht nach einem Kälteeinbruch
aus denn zwischen dem Hoch über Italien
und dem Tiefe mit dem britischen Inseln
wird es bei uns auch morgen wieder
richtig mild ungewöhnlich mild für
Anfang November heute Nacht fällt etwas
Regen hier im Nordwesten sonst ist es
mal mehr mal weniger stark bewölkt und
südlich der Donau es ist zum Teil auch
klar und dann bildet sich Nebel mit
geringen Sichtweisen im Alpenvorland
wird es nämlich kalt da sinken die
Temperaturen auf plus drei bis minus ein
Grad da droht nicht nur Bodenfrost
sondern sogar Luftfrost also Frost in
zwei Meter Höhe sonst sinken die
Temperaturen auf 11 bis 4 Grad am
Oberrhein sind es um die 6 und am
Oberrhein könnten morgen tatsächlich
noch mal an die 20 Grad erreicht werden
sonst liegen die Höchstwerte bei 13 bis
17 Grad hält sich der Nebel länger
bleibt es auch kühler das könnte hier im
Donautal der Fall sein besonders am
Vormittag bleibt es da wohl die ganze
Zeit trüb in Nordosten gibt es mehr
Sonne und von Westen werden besonders am
Nachmittag die Wolken dann immer dichter
sind erst zu hohe Schleierwolken es
dauert dann bis in die Nacht auf
Mittwoch bis das nächste Tief herankommt
mit Regenschauern an den Küsten auch mit
Gewittern danach geht es ruhiger weiter
am Freitag bei 9 bis 15 Grad guten Abend